les vacances se terminent et quelques
jours seulement nous séparent de la
rentrée scolaire mais pour les
adolescents voici encore quelques unes
de ces images de vacances c'est la vie
ici en plein air et en pleine forêt de
l'ardèche d'une troupe de scouts de
france la première lyon qui avait choisi
cette année pour camper le bois des
seigneurs près de bh sur les pentes du
gerbier de jonc
altitude 1200 m
c'est déjà pour ceux-ci la fin du camp
hélas après 20 jours de plein air
d'activités sportives et scout en
particulier
inspection gare aux mains sales voici
maintenant les installations du conte le
coin des patrouilles de cuisine et vous
le verrez
après ce rassemblement
traditionnellement scouts
le salut
office
et dans pleine forêt la construction du
traditionnel pont de singe
cette toile d'araignée
flottant sur le vide qui n'admet pas le
vestige
et que l'on emprunte à douze ou quinze
ans avec beaucoup d'incertitudes
[Musique]